hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book 11 of Marcus aurelius's
meditations we get a really
chock full passage in chapter 18 listing
off at least officially nine gifts from
the muses that are remedies for anger
and other kinds of being upset and then
it's going to turn out that there is a
tenth one from Apollo and I think we can
also say that there's at least two more
that are packed in there and so we're
going to go through each of these and
Marcus is telling us really about three
quarters of the way through that we
should keep in mind so right so to
remember to recall keep top of mind you
might say these nine points which in
Greek are kefalon or the beginnings of
chapters you could even say so each of
these can be expanded out into its own
mindset its own exercise its own insight
to be practically applied and he's
listing them off with a little bit of
discussion with some of them and we
should keep in mind each of these nine
points why nine because there's nine
Muses and so the muses are said to you
know put ideas into people's heads so
look at these wherever they come from
whether you get them on your own from
somebody other than Marcus from Marcus
himself look at them as sort of divine
gifts that are there to be remedies for
falling into anger hatred being upset
with your fellow human beings or perhaps
even with uh other things non-living
things you know the not allowing the
weather to tick you off but these are
mostly about human beings so the first
one he talks about my
relationships uh with with others so the
ways in which we are arranged in
relation to each other and what is that
well you know we can talk about like
Emperor and subjects but he says we came
into the world for the sake of each
other that's part of what it means to be
a human being from the stoic perspective
we're not just individual isolated
beings that can do whatever the hell
they want so long as they don't
transgress anybody's rights no we are
more positively here for each other and
he says or from another point of view I
came into it to be their Guardian as the
ram is of the flock of the bull of the
herd that's an idea he probably got from
Epictetus we find this in his discourses
and so you know he's held to a higher
standard getting angry will interfere
with that so reminding himself of the
relationships that he has can be quite
helpful and we can do that as well even
though we're not Emperors with our own
relationships the second he talks about
how you know people people are driven
by their beliefs their dog Mata what it
is that they think about things and so
he says what they're like eating you
know when they're at the table what
they're like in bed how proud they are
of what they do and all of this is a
matter again typical stoic doctrine of
what it is that these people are
thinking so if they screw up and tick
you off that's because they're doing the
things that are you know in accordance
with the way in which they see the the
world
the third is kind of related to this so
he says if they're right to do this
thing this thing that bothers you then
you have no right to complain you
shouldn't get angry at them they
actually don't even complain about what
they're doing don't raise a a fuss but
if they aren't doing the right thing
then you need to remind yourself about
certain things that pertain to people
doing the wrong thing what are they
they're doing it involuntarily or out of
ignorance they're not doing it just
because they choose evil for its own
sake and he says All Souls are prevented
from treating others as they deserve
just as they're kept from truth how
unwillingly nobody wants to be in the
dark I mean you could say well wait a
second what about people who
deliberately choose bad information
sources to confirm their biases well
that's because those dummies actually
think that's the right way to behave so
on some higher level they're they're
mixed stop about what's actually true
they're suffering from ignorance or you
know they're they're being driven by
their emotions well they're being driven
then by something that is not up to them
to to a large extent so he says this is
why people resent being called unjust or
arrogant or greedy any suggestion they
aren't good neighbors they don't like
that because they think that they're
actually doing the right thing so if you
can keep that in mind even though they
are doing the wrong thing then you don't
have to get angry at them as a result
the fourth one Marcus reminds himself
that you too sin if we want to translate
the word for sinning or making mistakes
or falling into error you also do that
kind of stuff and you know somebody
might respond and say well I don't do
exactly the same things as other people
he says well there's some you've avoided
but you still have the potential right
so you didn't sleep with your neighbor's
wife but you could have you could have
been seduced you didn't embezzle from
the uh the till you know stealing some
some bills well you didn't have the
opportunity but you could have that's
not Beyond you right we all can screw up
and he says even if cowardice kept you
from them or fear of what people would
say or equally some equally bad reason
so you didn't do the wrong thing but
that doesn't mean that you're not
capable of doing the wrong thing so you
know be a little bit more for giving or
understanding towards other people who
do in fact fall into error and do the
wrong thing he also says speaking of
mistakes and this is number five you
can't always be sure that what the
person is doing is actually a mistake it
could be a mistake from one perspective
but not from another he says a lot of
things are means to some other end you
have to know an awful lot before you can
judge other people's actions with real
understanding you know so a prime
example of this would be people who
suffered some terrible trauma and
they've got a unproductive way of
dealing with that and you look at them
and you're like they're choosing to do
the wrong thing and you can say yeah
okay they are choosing to do the wrong
thing on some level but they're doing it
as a coping mechanism it is a means to
an end of like not feeling like crap or
not having to deal with horrible
memories or pick whatever else you want
we don't actually know what ends are
being served until we get to know the
person quite well so you know we don't
have to take it personally when they do
things that we think in in general are
wrong
uh the next one he says when you lose
your temper or even feel irritated right
so when you're getting angry
remind yourself that human life
it's pretty short
you know
you think about the years and years and
years when we didn't exist the years and
years ahead when we won't exist and this
little brief moment of perhaps 80 years
that we get if we're lucky
and that helps put things into
perspective those people that you're
angry with they could die tomorrow you
never know whether you're going to have
a chance to actually you know guide them
to the right way or be reconciled with
them you know maybe it would be better
not to get so angry with them he says
before long all of us will be laid out
side by side corpses in the you know
catacombs or Cemetery or you know
funeral prior pick whatever else you
want right so that can be quite helpful
um number seven he talks about why we
get upset about things he says it's not
what they do other people do POI in
right what they the actions they engage
in that actually bothers us that's a
problem for their minds not ours what
bothers us so it's translated here as
misperceptions more literally it's our
assumptions and presumably misguided
assumptions
this is a term that Marcus uses quite a
lot sometimes translated as perceptions
or opinions but the better uh
translation for it is assumptions or or
judgments right so it's those things
that get us angry bothered he says
discard them be willing to give up
thinking of something as a catastrophe
and your anger is gone so you know what
would be a prime example of this you go
to a restaurant and you order something
and you know you've got kind of a very
specific order and you you make sure
that the server knows it and it comes to
the table and it's got the onions on it
that you can't stand and didn't want and
made sure that they wouldn't do it and
somehow the cook screwed up right
it's not something that you have to get
angry about because it's not a
catastrophe right it's not that big of a
deal pick the onions off right or if you
can't pick the onions off uh maybe order
another thing so he says how do you do
this recognizing you've suffered no
injury no disgrace unless this is the
only thing that can hurt you you're
doomed to commit innumerable innumerable
offenses
um you know so don't let these things
get to you
another thing that he says number eight
um getting angry
and grief Lupe these things are now the
translation here is how much more damage
anger and grief do than the things and
cause them but
damage is only one aspect of that
literally these these two emotions anger
and grief or pain are more difficult
means difficult and sojara potoron means
you know more difficult than other
things
don't let yourself fall into anger and
you won't have to deal with the
difficulties that arise out of feeling
angry or feeling grieved over things
and then the ninth one he's got a long
discussion here
he says uh this is kind of interesting
kindness you Menace which we can
translate as kindness being being a
gentle being nice to other people
um looking at them as if they're not you
know bad being being good to them he
says is unbeatable anike tone this comes
from the Greek word Nikkei to to have
Victory to have success to triumph over
so kindness can't be beaten nothing can
triumph over it if he says it's sincere
canacion right so fake kindness very
quickly can be beaten he says not ironic
not an Act and the not an act there's
translating
um you know
it's not what an actor is doing so he
says what can even the most vicious
person the hubrisistic person do if you
keep treating him with kindness and
gently set him straight if you get the
chance correct him cheerfully at the
exact moment he's trying to do you harm
no no my friend that isn't what we're
here for it isn't me who's harmed by
that it's you you're hurting yourself
and show him gently and without pointing
fingers that it's so that bees don't
behave like this or any other animals
with a sense of community and notice
what else he says don't do it
sardonically or meanly but
affectionately with no hatred in your
heart and not ex-cathedral not from up
on top or to impress third parties but
speaking directly so if you can talk to
somebody in the right way now you don't
control their own reactions but it makes
it much more likely that they can hear
you and realize that they're doing
themselves damage injury a disservice by
being bad to you by being kind to them
you create a situation where there's
some space for them to start doing
things right
now Marcus is going to say a few more
things which will you know count as
number 11 and number 12 but towards the
end he actually says oh here's another
thought from Apollo right so we got nine
Muses and Apollo and what is that this
is a very good one to expect bad people
not to injure others is crazy
it's no it's to ask the impossible right
so don't have unrealistic expectations
about bad people uh follows in Greek you
know covering a wide range everything
from like people who are kind of
screw-ups to the completely vicious and
and awful people and everything in
between they're going to behave the way
they're going to behave and part of that
is a product of you know what it is that
they they think and uh the mistakes that
they they make and in their judgments
and ideas
it's silly to expect that somebody who
you know hates you is going to treat you
nice right and he goes on and he says to
let them behave like that to other
people but to expect them to exempt you
is arrogant now he's talking to himself
as somebody who does have you know a lot
of authority and power and Prestige he
says that's the act of a tyrant so if
they're gonna act like jerks to their
peers to people below them they're going
to act like a jerk to you too
and to expect them to not do that
because you happen to be the emperor
kind of unrealistic for the rest of us
who are not Emperors well maybe we have
to be even more realistic about this
um I mentioned there's two other points
that he's going to make and maybe people
would number these differently so that
there's a 13th but I I think it's good
to say that there's 12. so he says along
with not getting angry at other people
try not to Pander or flatter them either
don't be a colax a a butt kisser as we
say a brown noser right both of these he
says are forms of selfishness
so coinos means common or you know
together and so these are ways in which
we set ourselves
apart from everybody else so selfishness
in the sense of like
treating ourselves as if we're just the
individuals who matter and we're not
connected to other human beings
so we should avoid anger and we should
also avoid flattery and we can we can
remember that these are forms of
selfishness and then he says both of
them will do you harm
both kissing people's butts and being
hostile to them getting angry taking
offense
the 12th one he says when you start to
lose your temper
remember so when you're falling into
anger remember this and this is about
manliness or virility and it's kind of
interesting it could also be extended
into courage which is connected with
that linguistically so anger getting
angry thumas thigh losing your temper
isn't manly
you know and Rico a lot of people think
that it is it's Macho it's you know
being a real man Marcus is saying
nope not at all
getting angry at people isn't being
manly it's actually being a whip it's
being uh a weak person not really a man
at all why because a real man behaves
differently than that and then notice
what he's going to to do he's going to
sort of extend the consideration so you
might say well this doesn't apply to
women no no it does because he says it's
courtesy and kindness or gentleness
this is the word for uh restraining
one's anger being in charge of one's
emotions having what we call these days
emotional intelligence right this is
distinctively not manly but human
that it belongs to the anthropost the
human being to actually be gentle with
other human beings
and then he goes on he says that's who
actually has strength is right and
nerves and guts not angry whiners
to react like that brings you closer to
impassivity and so to strength meaning
to to be uh gentle with others pain is
the opposite of strength so is anger
both are things that we suffer from and
yield to so if you want to be a real man
you need to get your anger under control
Marcus is saying to himself
and to us and if you want to be a decent
human being well you have to go beyond
just controlling your anger and actually
show gentleness restraint kindness to
other people so these are you know 12
different considerations that might help
you to control understand deal with your
anger Marcus is of course addressing
these to himself but we are so fortunate
as readers that we have this nice
listing with all of these and I I would
say uh practices that reinforce each
other you do these and you will ideally
be less and less of an angry person over
time